[російською] У той день, коли все трапилось, я був у школі.
[російською] Ми бігали дивитись на пожежу. Не вразило.
[російською] Коли ми прийшли — був димок,
станція затягнута як туманом.
[російською] І в принципі нічого цікавого ми не побачили.
[російською] Зате гелікоптери почали літати
над головами військові, величезні
[російською] з якимись прив'язаними кастрюлями.
[російською] Оце було цікаво.
[російською] Оце крило молодшої школи.
[російською] Ось під завалом якраз знаходиться
вхід в мій клас, де я вчився, в 3-Б класі.
[російською] Стандартна, типова школа.
З кожних сходів був чорний вихід.
[російською] Зазвичай закритий.
[російською] У нашій школі його використовували
для того, щоб прогулювати уроки.
[російською] Я зі своїм другом прогулюю якийсь черговий урок.
[російською] І ми знаходимо всередині цього
приміщення шкіряний футбольний м'ячик.
[російською] Ми про це розповідаємо усім,
не скупимося, даємо грати іншим.
[російською] У якийсь момент закидуємо його
на дах бойлерної в мене у дворі.
[російською] І, власне, все. М'ячик зник.
[російською] За кілька днів нас на перерві
ловить його власник.
[російською] Хуліган, на декілька років старший за нас.
[російською] Взяв нас на перерві так двох і провів бесіду,
[російською] за результатами якої
було прийнято спільне рішення,
[російською] що ми маємо протягом трьох днів
повернути йому м'ячик назад або по 10 рублів кожен.
[російською] Ховалися день, два, три. Не пам'ятаю.
[російською] А потім так доречно взривається
Чорнобильська атомна електростанція.
[російською] В евакуацію ми їдемо з таким світлим відчуттям.
[російською] З'являється додаткових три дні відтермінування
[російською] від зустрічі з першим в житті шантажистом.
[російською] 27 квітня о 12 дня
по міській системі сповіщень, по гучномовцю
[російською] вперше прозвучало повідомлення про евакуацію.
[російською] І за дві години почали подаватися автобуси.
[російською] Я весь цей час стирчав у вікні
і спілкувався з друзями, мама була на роботі.
[російською] Концепція евакуації подавалася
саме як тимчасове явище на декілька днів.
[російською] Нащо з собою брати щось велике,
глобальне, якщо ти їдеш всього на три дні.
[російською] З чуток — в наметовий табір.
[російською] Усі брали з собою мінімальний комплект одягу,
[російською] документи, якісь бутерброди,
[російською] і ставились до цього як до додаткових вихідних.
[російською] Я після аварії дуже хотів повернутися.
[російською] Це було протягом багатьох років.
[російською] Мені місто постійно снилося.
[російською] І от, зима 1992 року.
[російською] Ми через Славутич їдемо в Зону на автобусі.
[російською] І я майже п'ять годин
один пробродив по місту.
[російською] Ходив скрізь своїми місцинами дитинства.
[російською] Більшу частину поїздки просто проплакав.
[російською] Це був психологічно найскладніший візит.
[російською] І, напевно, тільки після цієї поїздки
[російською] я зрозумів для себе,
що нам немає куди повертатися.
[російською] До цього все ще вірив,
сподівався, що ми повернемося.
[російською] Але та поїздка, напевно,
і визначила те, чим я тепер займаюсь.
[російською] Знайшов свій спосіб повертатися.
[російською] Ліло!
[російською] Йди сюди, хороша моя, Ліло!
[російською] Лілочко, йди до мене, хороша моя, йди сюди!
[російською] Дві кобили дикі прибились до нас восени 2014 року.
[російською] Вийшли з зони відчуження десь через дірку.
[російською] І прийшли в село Дитятки,
де я вже рік як жив з сім'єю.
[російською] Поселились на полі навпроти мого дому.
[російською] Почали під'їдати залишки на городах у людей.
[російською] Подружились з сусідським жеребцем
і вирішили, що лишаються там жити.
[російською] Тут добре і багато їжі.
[російською] Ми зробили декілька спроб
повернути їх в зону відчуження.
[російською] Попереду вели цього жеребця,
до якого вони прибилися.
[російською] У зону декілька десятків кілометрів пішки.
[російською] Вони йшли за нами.
[російською] А за кілька днів повертались назад в Дитятки
і стало зрозуміло, що це не має сенсу.
[російською] І так ми їх не позбудемось.
[російською] І для них був побудований
тимчасовий вольєр
[російською] десь п'ятдесят на п'ятдесят метрів
[російською] на тій самій ділянці, де вони паслись.
[російською] Ми викупили [ту ділянку]
і зробили для них там це тимчасове укриття
[російською] Вони жили в цьому вольєрі.
Ми їх утримували, кормили.
[російською] Намагались пристроїти кудись безуспішно.
[російською] За цей час з'явилися два гібридних лоша
[російською] від того самого жеребця, до якого вони прибились,
[російською] і замість двох коней в нас вже стало четверо.
[російською] Восени 2016 року зі мною вийшов
на зв'язок координатор зоопарку в Межигір'ї
[російською] і запропонував авантюру:
спробувати перевезти коней
[російською] на територію оцього вольєру в Сухолуччі.
[російською] Десь день тривала вся ця операція,
і в результаті коней успішно перевезли сюди.
[російською] Так, це вони зараз такі оксамитові, літні.
[російською] А взимку в них така шерсть!
До того ж у лошат також.
[російською] Це домінантна ознака коней Пржевальського.
[російською] Хоч і гібридики.
Так? Ви мої гібрідики маленькі.
[російською] Чому вони нас точно навчили?
[російською] Розумінню того, що ми можемо жити в селі,
[російською] можемо бути власниками ферми,
[російською] розводити тварин і так далі.
Ну ми ж міські жителі.
[російською] Я в Прип'яті ріс в дитинстві,
потім все життя в Києві.
[російською] Ніколи на землі не ріс,
нічого не вирощував, тим більше коней.
[російською] Зараз ми розуміємо,
що нам це по силах, ми можемо це робити.
[російською] Я хочу сюди приїжджати
і буду приїжджати далі.
[російською] Але я розумію,
що жити вже тут будемо не ми.
[російською] Жити тут будуть олені,
лис Семен і його, дай Бог, діти.
[російською] Це найбільш унікальний
заповідник під відкритим небом,
[російською] де природа показує,
що попри і навіть всупереч
[російською] старанням людини вона все одно відновлюється.
[російською] Місія Прип'яті в цьому контексті —
глобальному, екологічному —
[російською] можливо навіть не навколишня екологія,
а екологія душі людини.
[російською] Це місце, в якому кожна людина може,
[російською] якщо захоче, змусити себе відчути
[російською] те, що пережили люди, які тут жили.
[російською] Поставити себе на їхнє місце.
[російською] Уявити, що це могло б статися
і з її містом.
[російською] Пропустити через себе
[російською] і в майбутньому жити так,
щоб після неї не залишались мертві міста.